jennifer and walker it's so nice to see
both of you i
absolutely love this film partly because
our canadian boy ryan reynolds is in it
but also this is a love letter to moms
which is so beautiful
you know right away i hugged my kids
right after that i miss them because
they're teenagers now i mean jennifer
are you finding your kids are less kissy
and huggy at this point
maybe sometimes but i still get i can't
complain i still get plenty of cuddles
but wait a minute we have more canadian
bonafides than i mean ryan reynolds
obviously he is vancouver vancouver is
ryan but we sean levy is our director
montreal born and bred and truly a true
canadian we shot in vancouver the whole
film was made with a canadian crew so
um we were just saying this is a very
canadian production so do you know the
canadian national anthem then
uh
da da da
[Music]
canadians you guys are and uh walker you
are absolutely brilliant it was so fun
watching you and the fact is you're in a
film with the hulk
deadpool and gamora i mean which one is
your favorite
electro analysis
i love it and the fact is when you're
watching this film i think a lot of
people think about what time in their
lives they would like to revisit again
and right away i said i'd love to see my
grandpa again what is that for you jen
i'm pretty happy where i am right now
but i would go back to any
time where my kids were babies or
toddlers or little
to play with them for another day and
hold them another day or
really i mean
any there is no time of your life where
that it wouldn't be interesting to go
back and have a look around
the cuddles it's all about the cuddles
uh and and walker uh what did ryan tell
you to find his inner youth
character as if
sorry
what did ryan tell you in advice in
terms of playing your character
um
well
he
i guess you didn't have to tell me too
much yes i've watched
i've like stepped too too many times
like i think i've
watched it more hours than i've lived
i don't think that that was necessary
honestly i think these two are
cut from the same cloth and it's like
ryan always says about working with
walker that it was having the best toy
imaginable because anything he said to
walker walker would say exactly the way
ryan would say it they were they just
have the same timing the same
um
the same facility with language with
comedy and with drama walker has major
dramatic tracks in this movie and action
as well it's pretty good you're so good
you're so good to watch yeah and then we
get to see you with mark ruffalo again i
mean you guys were together what in 2004
for 13 going on 2 30. it must have been
nice to be back on set together yeah
um it was
really comforting it really felt like
coming home and i think
our history certainly
very much informed the um the one scene
that we have in this movie together
i love that and jen have to tell you i
follow you on tick tock and you are so
good at what you do and you're baking
and everything that you bring to do you
have fun doing it
oh yeah i would only put it up that's
why you only see me
post you know
probably half as much if as other people
or maybe a little more than half as much
but i can only put up what i truly find
fun and funny and if it isn't there then
i just don't put anything up at all but
thank you i'm glad you enjoyed it yeah i
love it i've tried your recipes i
absolutely love it so thank you so much
to both of you congratulations on this
film and yes canada right
yes we'll work on our canadian anthem
okay next time we see each other
okay thank you so much take care thanks
everybody take care bye